i
[Música]
cómo
en mexico tras el regreso a clases
presenciales el pasado 30 de agosto la
secretaria de educación informó que 135
mil escuelas abrieron sus puertas de un
total de 260 mil que hay en la educación
básica en el país y 12.6 millones de
alumnos asistieron de una matrícula de
25 millones y es que algunos padres de
familia decidieron no llevar a sus hijos
por temor a un contagio en el aula en
ese sentido la secretaria de educación
informó que en 88 escuelas detectaron
casos de kobe 19 pero solamente 39 de
ellas cerraron sus puertas como medida
sanitaria si bien la curva epidémica va
a la baja en méxico entre el 15 de
agosto y el 5 de septiembre los
contagios de niños y menores de edad
aumentaron en 37 mil casos que
requirieron hospitalización y en 1300
los que no necesitaron ser internados no
obstante el responsable del manejo de la
epidemia hugo lópez gatell reitera que
el riesgo en la población infantil es
muy bajo y que no hay evidencia de que
el regreso a clases presenciales haya
provocado un aumento de contagio
[Música]
un cuarto de los hospitales en el país
con unidades de cuidado intensivo
reportó que al menos el 95% de sus camas
están ocupadas en promedio en el país el
80 por ciento de las camas de cuidado
intensivo en los hospitales están
ocupadas y es que eeuu vuelve a pasar la
barrera de los 100.000 hospitalizados al
día por cuenta de la variable delta ya
ha generado una nueva ola de casos que
tiene muchos hospitales sobre todo al
sur del país en capacidad máxima y en
modo de crisis nuevamente cerca de 650
mil estadounidenses han muerto a causa
del virus se están reportando 150.000
casos al día y esta semana el total de
infectados superó los 40 millones la
preocupación se extiende a menores de
edad que con su regreso a clase su tasa
de hospitalización se ha multiplicado
por 5 entre junio y agosto
hay preocupación en alemania por el
regreso a clases tras las vacaciones de
verano en momentos en que el país
afronta una delicada cuarta ola de la
pandemia del coronavirus que afecta de
manera particular a los no vacunados y a
los jóvenes las autoridades continúan
con su meta de garantizar la
presencialidad siempre que sea posible
de garantizar que clases enteras no
tengan que estar en cuarentena cuando se
confirma un caso positivo pero esto está
resultando difícil en especial en zonas
donde se ha informado de un aumento en
el número de escolares infectados tras
el regreso a clases luego de las
vacaciones y por supuesto hay un debate
aquí en alemania cuando se considera que
no hay una vacuna contra el coronavirus
aprobada para los menores de 12 años
[Música]